[Musique]
elle veut transmettre le petit nom de la
vie adeline breton est une touche-à-tout
et sculpte modèle travail le carton le
papier le bois ou encore le plâtre ce
qui est commun à tous ces travaux là
c'est des choses qui s'imbriquent des
éléments qui s'imbriquent toujours
ensemble c'est comme un travail de
couturière pénélope qui tisse sa toile
et voilà il ya un côté très couture de
fabrication un peu comme un jeu de lego
en fait tous et des éléments qui
tiennent en équilibre
j'assemble beaucoup j'assemble et
j'empile donc je m'amuse comme un enfant
je coule je fais des empreintes jeu
moule des objets du quotidien
et moi j'aime me laisser parler
l'extraordinaire dans l'ordinaire un
travail au long cours pour celle qui
baigne dans l'art depuis l'enfance le
déclic un moment un instant difficile de
sa vie
un gouffre combler lors d'un voyage en
autriche
c'était dans un atelier relativement
classique aux beaux-arts atelier
matériaux nouveaux on sait de la résine
du ciment que des matériaux lourds et
moi j'avais envie de parler de légèreté
donc c'était un peu le paradoxe quand je
suis parti à vienne dans les ateliers
y'a rien aux beaux-arts on vous donne
tout c'est là où on se rencontre
vraiment qu'on est gâtés à vienne faut
faire un projet très construit pour moi
j'ai fait comme tout le monde là-bas les
étudiants travaillent avec des papiers
l'espace adeline breton vous invite à
prendre le temps d'observer de penser
devancé création des oeuvres souvent
partie d'objets du quotidien
soixante dix d'entre elles sont à
découvrir à montigny le bretonneux